Ukraine's commander-in-chief is warning
of a fresh Russian Onslaught on the
capital Kiev in the coming weeks both
sites have indicated there will not be a
Christmas ceasefire moscow's latest
strikes on civilian infrastructure have
knocked out critical power supplies in
the cities of Carson and khakive
Ukrainian infrastructure is coming under
almost daily Russian bombardment this
among the latest attacks with rockets
severely damaging a warehouse in the
northeastern city of Hawkeye prompting
the city mayor to urge residents to stay
in shelters investigators and War crime
prosecutors on site soon after to
inspect damage and collect evidence
Russia conducts strikes on civilian
infrastructure as you see the warehouse
was completely empty there was no
connection to the military whatsoever
in southern Ukraine and the liberated
city of her son emergency teams do their
best to tackle a fire after more
shelling according to officials here the
city is now completely without power for
those who remain life is a daily
struggle after nearly 10 months of war
the U.N High Commissioner for human
rights is now warning that more strikes
could lead to a further serious
deterioration in the humanitarian
situation missile strikes on civilian
infrastructure including energy
facilities and hydroelectric power
stations are exposing millions of
civilians especially persons in
situations of vulnerability to extreme
hardship during the winter months
over 10 million consumers
are facing Cuts in electricity
and millions are cut off from a regular
supply of water and Heat
Russia has rejected a proposal of a
Christmas Truce with Pro Moscow
officials in the occupied city of
dunesque blaming Ukraine for this attack
an apartment building and a hospital
among the buildings damaged in the
shelling a senior Ukrainian military
General now says Russia is digging in
for a long war in Ukraine and still
wants to conquer the entire country
the Kremlin realizes that in the short
term it's impossible to achieve victory
in the war
thus it's seeking to turn the conflict
into a prolonged armed confrontation
aimed at exhausting Ukraine and our
partners
there are now concerns that any new
Russian assault could come from
neighboring Belarus whose Armed Forces
continue to hold combat Readiness drills
close to its border with Ukraine
our correspondent Nick Connelly is in
Kiev he told us why Russia's claims that
it's only hitting military Targets in
Ukraine just don't add up
well obviously they are still claiming
that this is about basically depriving
Ukraine's military of the power and the
logistics to make their successes on the
battlefield happen obviously that
doesn't really cut a lot of ice when
you're here on the ground and seeing the
kind of targets that are being hit but I
think there's a level to which they've
basically given up trying to create uh
kind of coherent narrative for people
here in Ukraine people in the west they
basically know that that audience is
lost to them so this is all about the
story to People Back Home in Russia who
maybe want to believe what they're told
and to people in third countries who
maybe don't have an ability to really
fact check those claims and I think
there's also just a conviction in Moscow
that they are just so big and they are
so important because of their nuclear
status their you know seat at the
security Council that basically people
will have to talk to them whatever they
do whatever the kind of war crimes
potentially committed by their troops
here in Ukraine at the end of the day
outside Powers the US Europe will come
and speak to them so there's basically
not much of a kind of perceived
impulsive kind of you know need to
really stick to the ordinary rules of
War they can basically get away with
that they seems to be what they think
well joining us now for more on the
military situation in Ukraine is Mike
Martin he's a war studies senior fellow
at King's College London good to have
you with us Mike now Ukrainian officials
say they expect Russia to launch another
large-scale offensive early next year
possibly aiming to take the capital Kiev
do you see that happening
I don't actually see that as very likely
um firstly I don't think the Russians
have that intent they've very clearly
signaled that they're interested in the
donbass in the east of the country I
think their designs on Kiva over and
secondly I don't think they have the
capability Russia at the moment is very
much on the defensive in Ukraine and to
launch a huge another offensive all the
way around coming from Belarus I think
is unrealistic
now it's been reported that the U.S is
preparing to send Patriot missile
systems to Ukraine do you think that
would be a game changer
the Patriot missile system is a highly
effective anti-aircraft system and so
what it would do is enable the
ukrainians to at the moment they're sort
of shooting down about 70 of the
missiles that are coming their way they
could increase that coverage and knock
out almost all of the missiles that are
heading towards Ukrainian cities is it
going to change the Strategic balance of
the war no because the Russian attacks
on the Ukrainian cities themselves are
not changing the Strategic balance of
the war but it will mean that a lot more
Ukrainian civilians survive the winter
what about battle tanks Mike there's uh
Ukraine is begging for battle tanks
Germany is under massive pressure to
send them why is nobody sending battle
tanks to Ukraine
they it's a very good question
um so Ukraine needs these tanks in order
to go on the offensive at a large scale
um they are somewhat complex and have
quite long logistical Tales so it's not
just a question of the tanks you need
the crews and the logistics and the fuel
to run them
um but I wonder whether these fall in
the bucket of is this escalatory if we
include these in the package but I think
eventually the West is going to get
around to sending main battle tanks to
Ukraine
Russia says that sending Patriot
missiles would be an escalation that
would have consequences what do you make
of that
I I think that we've heard this before
from Russia so when we were sending uh
anti-tank missile systems they said that
was escalatory then when we sent longer
range artillery the high Mars that
everyone's heard so much about that was
escalatory Russia says that everything
is escalatory
um the question for the West is I think
most mostly what we end up doing is
thinking that things escalatory and then
sending them anyway so the quicker that
we send them the better and the shorter
the time until the war ends
Mike thank you very much for your
analysis that was Mike Martin senior
fellow in war studies at King's College
London
thank you